first on CBS mornings Ryan Reynolds is
making a very personal Milestone public
and asking you to follow his example
Rob and I both we turned 45 this year
and you know part of being this age is
getting a colonoscopy it's a simple step
that could literally and I mean
literally save your life
Reynolds and fellow actor Rob mcelhaney
allowed video cameras to record their
colonoscopies the co-owners of the
wrexham soccer club in Wales want to
raise awareness about the rising rates
of colon cancer in people younger than
50. Ryan Reynolds went first arriving
bright and early to his appointment with
our favorite gastroenterologist Dr John
lapuke
I would never normally have any medical
procedure put on camera and then shared
good morning it's not every day that you
can raise awareness about something that
will most definitely save lives
going in
that's enough motivation for me to let
you in on a camera being shut down my
Ryan hello it's the first time you've
had a colonoscopy yeah and filming it
you're filming is like also it's just
awful the procedure itself doesn't take
long we talk you know 30 minutes
something like that it's done stunningly
effective
[Music]
I'm an a graham cracker
[Music]
you did such a good prep that I was able
to find an extremely subtle
polyp that was on the right side of your
colon this was potentially life-saving
for you I'm not kidding I'm not being
overly dramatic I mean this is exactly
why you do this okay you had no symptoms
yeah all right man okay yeah I'm
thrilled thank you so much for this
seriously thank you for pushing me to do
this this is the polyp I put I just cut
it off with a snare and it's gone you
are interrupting the natural history of
a disease of something of a process that
could could have ended up you know
developing it to cancer and and causing
all sorts of problems instead you're not
only diagnosing the polyp you're taking
it out I figure I can't go wrong in
terms of comparing myself to Ryan
they either find nothing and that means
my colon was cleaner than his or they
find a polyp all set and it's either
bigger than his which is awesome
or it's smaller than his
which means I had less of an opportunity
to have cancer either way I went
[Music]
so easy good how do you feel
good today we found three polyps
they were small they were not a big deal
but certainly a good thing that we found
them early and removed them thank you
thank you so much I'll see you uh I'll
see you in a couple years
foreign
s us right now good morning so how did
all of this come about
Ryan came to me you know I I'm very
protective of my patients privacy but he
reached the age of screening which is
now 45. it used to be 50.50 and it
dropped down and why why'd you drop it
dropped down because we're seeing colon
cancer in younger people for for reasons
that are not clear but he wanted to
raise awareness and so he said let's do
this PSA so his idea not your idea not
my idea but you went in there you did
your job you found what you described as
a subtle polyp yeah is that typical and
also Rob had a polyp as well right I
know each one of them had a polyp which
potentially it had the potential to over
time turn into cancer totally benign
right now giving no symptoms you find it
you pluck it out and instead of
potentially getting cancer you don't get
cancer wow Tony and I are the exact same
age and I could tell when you were
watching that you were thinking what I
was thinking it's going to be us soon so
I know the age is 45 is there any other
signs that someone should go in sooner
absolutely because you guys are both 41.
41. I've got some time to prepare I'll
watch that video a few times get used to
it I'm so glad that you brought that up
Nate because these recommendations now
down to 45 are for people at average
risk right if you have symptoms if you
have a change in your stool and you have
to get specific if you notice bleeding
if you notice narrowing in the stool you
have abdominal pain if you've been told
of iron deficiency anemia and you're
tired because of that it could be
because of invisible blood loss from a
polyp or an early cancer that you don't
even know about if you have symptoms go
to your health care provider and and get
it evaluated well I know you are
discreet because I'm one of your
patients I've been to Dr Hook several
times and he told me that I have a long
and winding colon yes yeah just sit with
that for a second is that unusual yes
how is Ryan's colon it was perfect
on screen on a serious note you know
talk about that prep and I know people
don't love it I hate the prep is there
nothing else to do there are so
important to do it there are there are
different types of prep I know people
are scared of that there that you can
have now a combination of of having
fluid and pills you'll figure out a way
to clean it out but the bottom line is
that because they were so they both did
such a good job you're able to see these
subtle polyps and you know normally you
think about a polyp up on a stock and
it's easy how can you miss it but now
we're realizing there are more and more
flat polyps very subtle and when you do
a good job as Ryan did it was perfect
job I was able to find it and we should
also say John that it really is nothing
to be afraid of because it really is a
piece of cake I know the imagery is what
freaks people out but if you do the prep
and that's just drinking the stuff that
makes you clean out everything you
really are out you feel nothing you
honestly feel nothing yeah and it's not
something that should scare people it
shouldn't and we have to raise awareness
and there is a myth that you know about
men and women you know women and men get
colon cancer just about equally yeah so
like you said it could be life-saving
yes it could be life-saving three and a
half years and counting four years yeah
we're there see you all together we'll
go together we'll bring the cameras yeah
oh boy all right it'll be your idea now
my polyp will be bigger oh man Dr John
lapuk thank you we appreciate you to see
the entire Ryan Reynolds and Rob
mcelhaney video visit our CBS morning's
Twitter Facebook or Instagram pages also
visit leadfrombehind.com or lead from
behind.org excuse me for more
information and thanks to Ryan and Rob
for doing it was great that's huge
because I know he's a big personality
but he's actually in Blake Lobby are
very private in their lives yeah I think
it was a big deal for him to do this